hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast interpretation of
hematology veterinary scatter grams in
normal and pathological conditions
presented by dr. Kate Cresswell founder
and owner and independent consultant at
Westbrook biomarker and Pharma consult
of consulting options Valdes of laborat
and I'll be your moderator for today's
events we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
elaborates and sponsored by sis max for
more information about our sponsor go to
WWE XCOM forward slash us if you're
looking for multi species hematology
analyzers go to the products and
services menu button click on Hemet
ology multi-species
before we begin I want to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
anytime you want during the presentation
just click on the ask a question box
located in the far left of your screen
type your questions into the drop down
box that appears on that screen and
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation if you're having trouble
seeing or hearing this presentation
click on the help desk button located at
the promotional board at the bottom
center of your screen or use that ask a
question button and let us know you're
having the problem this presentation is
educational and that's offers continuing
education credits please click on the
accreditation button located in the
promotional board at the bottom center
of your screen and follow the process
for obtaining your credits please join
me now in welcoming our presenter dr.
Kate Cresswell I now will turn the
presentation over to her welcome dr.
Criswell thank you this intention will
focus on the interpretation of
hematology veterinary scatter grams as a
disclosure they have received an
honorarium from Sizzix for today's
presentation and importantly we will be
looking at a multitude of case studies
and it's very important to recognize
that not all case studies are identical
and although we can use them as good
learning opportunity
why
chase does not necessarily know the
scatter grams that we're going to look
at today were predominantly gathered
from Sizzix analyzers and in
particularly the xt 2000 i and the x NV
both of them hematology analyzers
specified for animal use the SIS mix XM
platform actually can be used for both
human and veterinary applications the xn
is a product of growth from the more
original series which is all the SIS mix
X E series but the exomes for humans has
actually been in has been in use since
2012
there have been multiple updates of
footprints and other efficiency and
scientific improvements since then when
we look at the veterinary applications
the first application for sis mix was
the entity application and it had a
release date of 2005 so a good history
to it with over a decade of being able
to analyze hematology samples with this
technology the conversion to the X and V
or veterinary application relatively new
with July therefore you're going to find
in this presentation I've actually put a
couple of human applications we call
them one of the other multi species and
you'll find that it's very relevant
since this is the same new release for
the xnv using some of the human
application will show you what you might
expect to see in an animal package so
both X T and X n X n platforms use a lot
utilize laser flow cytometry for cell
characterization as the image shows the
analyzer uses a laser beam at 633
nanometers and as that cell passes
through the light it has the ability to
scatter light and the analyze has
analyzer has the ability to capture that
light scatter the light scattered in a
forward direction will indicate cell
size the light scattered in side scatter
will determine internal complexity such
as the lobule arity or lack thereof of
the nucleus and lastly the siz mix
technology uses an rna-dna probe so that
we can also capture fluorescent light
earth panels will look at is called the
wdf channel and this is the channel used
for the predominant WBC differential the
scattergram on the left shows you the
populations that normally can be
discerned when running a hematology
sample through this particular analyzer
we see several categories the pink being
typically our lymph category the green
in this particular case being Manos the
Aqua being a combination of neutrophils
and basophils and the red being an
eosinophil population this information
is captured by capturing fluorescence
which is our DNA marker on the y-axis
and side scatter light looking at the
complexity of the cell so it makes sense
that cells that are more complex ones
who have the biggest granules the ones
that have maybe the most lobes a nucleus
would be the furthest to the right and
those cells that are the largest in size
should be higher on the y-axis from this
we can see this particular channel
allows us to differentiate limps
monocytes and neutrophils and
eosinophils but we will see as we look
at case studies this channels also going
to allow us to protect that there may be
a typical lymphocytes or immature WT
so to summarize this wdf panel or the
white cell differential for essence
panel we find that the leukocytes are
classified according to content of
nucleic acid be that RNA or DNA and the
internal complexity or sites center of
light in healthy individual
or animals we find that there are four
different populations that are clearly
discernible we'll find that our basal
numbers actually need to be determined
in a different town
so in essence are immature granulocytes
and give us a six part parental it would
be see that we can actually also
determine immature granulocytes a
difference in the xn technology is aging
algorithms and this change in algorithms
abbreviated SAFF loss or Susan adaptive
flagging algorithm shape recognition
actually incorporates a linear
discriminations of cell clusters
allowing a better differentiation
between the four normal populations in
the WBC differential alright so that
other channels at WN are channel the WN
are channel cell stands for white cell
and RBC scattergram this their
scattergram although it lumps together
all of our other white cells that we
talked about it has the ability using
forward scatter and side fluorescence on
y and x axis respectively to be able to
differentiate our bezos since they will
be above our normal population
it will also differentiate nucleated red
blood cells so NMR prides identification
of basophils nucleated red and we also
have a debris area and most people
discount the debris area but we're going
to find in these case studies that even
the debris channel can be important in
interpreting abnormal scatter grams
examples that you might find in that
debris category might indicate there's a
platelet clumping problem or potentially
even parasitic infections so a couple of
other scatter grams that says mix
provides for us is a reticulocyte
scatter gram reticulocytes we recognize
our red blood cells that have been
released from the bone marrow and still
retain RNA but no longer retain a
nucleus as such we can stain that RNA
and we pan as shown on the image on the
right be able to determine populations
of reticulocytes that have low
fluorescence LF our moderate
fluorescence MFR or high fluorescence HF
our high fluorescence reticulocytes this
indicates the amount of RNA remaining in
the cell actually is a good indicator of
bone marrow activity the more RNA
present the closer to the time of
release from bone marrow so this
immature reticulocyte fraction becomes
an important indicator of bone marrow
activity both the X T and the X n
platforms are going to give us
reticulocyte counts give us in both the
absolute and percentage of manner and
also this immature reticulocyte counts
and we do it as we say by having the y
axis being forward scatter with size our
red blood cells are much larger than
platelets so typically in particularly
in normal samples we have a good
separation between red cells that are
much larger than platelets another
scattergram that is present on both the
X T and X n platforms is called the
platelet o scattergram platelet counts
can be obtained on either analyzed by
two methods one is an impedance method
simply counting through the age-old
method of breaking in an electrical
current as the cell passes through but
optical methods can incorporate the use
in this particular case of a fluorescent
dye and we're going to find that it
allows us to have greater separation of
red cells and platelets particularly
when there are pathologic conditions
such as micro psychosis just a sites or
other red cell fragments that could be
the size of platelets and be erroneously
counted as such or in contrast giant
platelets which can be the size of red
cells and
counted as such the xn brings us yet
another platelet scattergram and this
platelet scattergram is now called our
platelet F scattergram and in it we says
max has incorporated yet a different
platelet specific fluorescent dye which
in this case will stay in rough
endoplasmic reticulum and mitochondria
with this particular scattergram we are
looking again at forward scatter so red
cells are large platelets are small in
this case where our x axis now shows us
side scatter fluorescence and by this
type of algorithm this type separation
we find that we get even better
separation between red cells and
platelets under those pathologic
conditions and we will see a few case
studies as we press let's start looking
at the veterinary scatter grams this is
our first one but this is a
representative scatter gram this is a
dog and we will find from the ones that
I've shown you already that perhaps it
looks a little more linear it means that
neutrophils and lymphocytes and
monocytes are kind of more linear that
although morphology is similar between
species for white cells it is not
identical and there can be various
differences there can be differences in
lobule arity there can be differences in
granularity and that's what's going to
cause the cluster formations of these
various cell types so it becomes it's
really important that we're dealing with
species specific software when we try to
do WBC differentials because of these
subtle differences but yet important
differences between our white blood
cells we can find however that once we
learn how to interpret abnormalities in
these scatter grams that they're going
to be very helpful for you trying to
predict pathologic
even across species and even though the
basic scattergram may be slightly
different you're also going to find that
if you are familiar with former versions
such as the XE or XT that if you convert
to the xn you will find that those
pathologic scatter grams again are going
to be highly similar so let's show you a
publication from ASC VP in 2012 this was
represented as a typical presentation of
dog scatter grams collected on the Civic
see here is that wdf scatter gram we
talked about and we can see we have a
good neutrophil thing good neutrophil
population lymphocyte mono and eel
population when we look at the W and our
population again we can see the bezos
pulled out readily when we look at the
retail sites of this dog we find good
separation between red cells and the
much smaller platelets we see very few
reticulocytes in this dog but it still
could be normal
here is our platelet o that we talked
about and again we see good separation
between red cells and platelets and
again we can now see immature fractions
for both reticulocytes and platelets and
measured as we need and the last two
scatter grams that we haven't out are
actually ones that are generated as
Gaussian distributions of our red cells
and platelet histograms and they are
equally important in our interpretation
of abnormal scatter grams one thing we
will notice is that pre and post the
Gaussian peak that they should return to
normal and that when they don't
this is our first evidence that perhaps
we have a pathologic condition and
perhaps we should investigate further
we'll also find that the SIS mix allows
us to do us or actually provides us
statistics so it provides us what we
call a red cell distribution width and
it provides us an
d or a CV of these and the larger our
statistics the larger the distribution
so again it becomes a trigger for us to
look at what could be causing a greater
variation in either red cell or platelet
size all right so let's look at some
differences between some various species
so this shows some normal wdf petagrams
for cat dog and horse
I particularly called out a OS because I
thought this was actually an interesting
one so on the Left we have a cat sample
this is drawn labeled as 0 hours meaning
this is a fresh sample the dog as a
fresh sample the horse for example next
to it we now have a cat a dog and a
horse it's the same sample but now at 72
hours now the important message of here
if you look at anything at 72 hours you
lose the distinct separation of
population a human or a veterinary
sample is actually the appropriateness
of your sample so the age of your sample
and the viability of your cells once you
pass that as I've commented before not
all cells not all species are going to
look absolutely identical if you look at
the cat and the dog we have kind of this
linear distribution of neutrophils
lymphocytes monocytes both of them kind
of have that if you look the horse the
horse has a greater degree typically
that the neutrophil population is pushed
farther on the x axis more typical to
what you would find in humans and I will
tell you monkeys kind of do this same
application so the importance of this is
that they can be different one important
application I saw in this publication
was actually where eosinophils fell for
this particular cat sample and you can
see they're actually very high on the y
axis or typically and in our most of our
examples we expect them to be right next
to the neutrophil population so indeed
they can vary and I've given you
examples of various eosinophils that
occur across species and you can see
that although they are very similar they
are not the same for instance if I look
at the applying or the dog I actually
have these very very large globules
they're granulation is extremely large
in contrast the granulation of cat
eosinophils is usually very small very
compact because we are measuring light
scatter these small differences can make
large differences in where the
population actually resides all right so
let's look at where some of these
abnormal cells reside within our wdf and
I've included two different diagrams for
whichever one you find easier to
interpret one that looks more like the
scattergram on the right the one that
maybe looks a little more like a cartoon
on the left
whichever serves you better to learn
this please go ahead and use that
alright so we've talked to four
population here's our neutrophil and
bezos in our aquamarine on this
right-hand diagram here's our
lymphocytes in pink our monocytes in
green and our eosinophils to the right
and in red well as I said some may be
slightly different the populations we
see most frequently one of the most
frequently is a left shift or IG imager
granulocytes and meta Milo sites Milo
sites these cells are larger than normal
mature neutrophils so you would expect
them to be in the same position as
neutrophils but higher on the y-axis
because this is going to mean I have a
larger cell I have a larger nucleus
should have greater fluorescence so they
will be right above your neutrophil
population
another population we haven't talked
about is our nucleated rep he said we
like assess them from the wnr but you
can likely still see that they're going
to be present on this on the fluorescent
scattergram typically they are the size
of a red cell but they have a nucleus in
them so we would expect them to be
smaller than our lymphocytes and
typically below them so n RBC's
nucleated red blood cells can be seen
even if they're enumerated on the other
larger cells atypical lymphocytes blast
cells all of them have much larger
nucleus much higher nuclear -
cytoplasmic ratios this high nucleus
this high DNA content will cause them to
have very high fluorescence levels and
we would expect them to be much higher
on our y-axis so with that we'll start
our case studies and our first one was a
effort from the XT analyzer in this
example of immature granulocytes we can
see it indicated on our scatter scatter
gram in dark blue and indicated with an
arrow of IG and with image for
granulocytes when you're interpreting
petagrams you should always look for
where are your normal populations we
should have a normal debris we do we
should have normal lymphocytes we do we
should have normal monocytes we do we
should have normal neutrophils normal
eosinophils we do but in this case we
actually have something extra we have
this population that the analyzers
regular recognizes as different you the
neutrophil population and it actually
flags it for us so that when we look at
our vast number parameters that come we
can say do I have a flag the answer is
yes I have a flag I think we are dealing
with immature granulocytes and in this
case it does indeed flag for us that I
have high numbers of IGS both percentage
in absolute and it triggers us then to
do a microscopic difference
so the abnormal scattergram becomes that
first step to say I need to go further
on this one and with this one with the
manual Jeff we can see we have a slight
elevation in bands and that's a few meta
myocytes so it was an accurate predictor
that immature granule sites were present
this one and as I said I would use a few
human applications and that's because
some of the flagging has been enhanced
with the xn application and this is
actually a very nice feature to have in
this particular application human albeit
again we do the same thing where are my
normal population so I have limps I have
Manos
I have neutrophils I have EOS I again in
this one I have an even larger
population of immature granulocytes so
that you would expect as you trigger a
Manuel microscopic differential you
would see more immature granulocytes but
beyond that with new flagging we find
that the xn is actually going to tell us
where on this x axis this the midpoint
of this position really resides and this
gives us an estimation of whether these
neutrophils could be hypo granulated if
they're shifted to the left or hyper
granulated if they're shifted right and
why is that important it becomes again
another piece of the puzzle and another
important indicator in this case you're
looking at population it increases the
granulation of the cell you have hyper
granulated cells and is consistent to
that this individual may have an
infectious process all right so next
study and I purposely didn't label this
one so that we could go forward through
it and see as this particular animal
progresses and it's a dog and here's our
first day we do the same as we always do
lymphocytes monocytes neutrophils and
AOS in their normal population and we
can see with the circle that there's
apps there is a small
population above the neutrophils so we
might suggest that on day one when this
dog was seen that there might have been
a low level of immature granulocytes as
we progressed to day five even without
looking at the values that are obtained
if you have day one scattergram a day
five scattergram you can say this animal
is different and this animal is
different in that they have greatly
increased there are a number of immature
granulocytes beyond that we actually
have a population a small population
that's even higher and that might
question us of whether this animal has
such a pronounced left shift that there
might be present two blasts again you're
only going to really resolve this
through a microscopic differential but
it is consistent with the actual
diagnosis of this animal which actually
sees all right next one again an ASCP
example and this one I put because I
think it has a nice application what you
can do with this is mix alright so this
one was on X T and this was a dog again
and seemingly pink lymphocytes green
monocytes and I now have two grey
population well what happens when the
analyser is uncertain of what a
population is instead of giving it the
color that you're looking for for a
specific cell type it may gray out
population if you were looking at this
and say well if it's a normal dog so be
the one on the left is the neutrophil
and the one on the right is going to be
the essential module and as this person
did they reanalyzed its okay so one of
the features of Sizzix is I can
reanalyze these and I can actually move
the gates and they did so they made this
my EO population seemingly EO population
neutrophil and you can see they actually
even move the lymphocyte population and
I had to pick it I probably would have
picked where they picked as well so we
now have one that looks more like a
normal population except that this eel
population looks really higher than
normal it's a really big robust
population so you would never want to
accept a reanalysis without looking
microscopically but it is again a good
indication that something needs to be
done and that's something in this
particular case it was a canine eosin
affiliate you certainly would look at
your data and your data tells you that
it had high EOS but again confirmation
comes down to a microscopic differential
so that you can confirm what is there
and if indeed you confirm the there's no
reason that you cannot report out your
reanalysis values but you do need that
confirmation right it's for all right so
case for again a dog and it looks kind
of similar to what we've been looking at
in our previous studies in this
particular case we see that instead of
this entire population being stained
green I actually seemingly have these
cells that are wrapping around the sides
of the mono and the ones on the top or
it's a different floor this leads me to
assume that these are truly monocytes so
certainly drives you to looking at your
data more closely and in this case it
does okay I do have somewhat higher
lymphocytes but I don't really have any
other clue of what might be going on so
you in this case would also want to be
able to do morphology and in this
particular case it would not be uncommon
that you might find cells that look like
these are these indeed are atypical
lymphocytes some individuals still call
them viral lymphocytes and they are
large lymphocytes that have
abnormal staining the blue staining
sometimes is consistent with function of
immunoglobulins by these by these
lymphocytes and because they are larger
they fall in a category where they would
have a larger larger nucleus and they
would have greater fluorescence and
they're different from our normal
lymphocyte population and this indeed
was and it was a case where of a viral
infection and a more reactive
lymphocytosis in this particular dog all
right so another change in in the xn as
far as flagging and I put this here
because some of the flagging differences
are is kind of nice too
so it uses again dating of cells that
are larger than our normal lymphocyte
population and uses an algorithm to
detail to tack detect whether there's a
difference and we will get flagging let
us know that we actually have reactive
lymphocytes or potentially have
activated monocytes and those that are
actually high enough on the y-axis
potentially could be plasma cells or
other types of class all right so I've
included for monocytosis a couple of
human ones if they didn't have the
veterinary counterpart for the xn but I
thought they were still a good learning
opportunity so looking at this
particular scattergram we again find
lymphocytes in purple monocytes in green
our neutrophils are blue at a very very
scant eosinophils
you look pretty much in a normal
population this one what the monocyte
population might be a bit higher on the
y-axis then but it's pretty much in a
normal position therefore we might
expect ok because of the magnitude of
this we
hope that when we look at the values
that we would have higher numbers of
monocytes in a single field but their
morphology might actually be quite
normal as in this case in contrast and
again this is an accent scattergram and
this one came with a diagnosis of acute
monocytic leukemia and you can ask
yourself was this different in the last
one where it was just a monocytosis i
mean it becomes clearly yes in this case
we have probably a set of Manos that are
down here in a normal size and maybe
normal morphology but we have a pretty
large population of Manos that are
shifted in mono area that are shifted
fairly high so that when we do this
review microscopically more
characteristically you are now going to
find blasts and in this case they were
characterized as mono blasts
they are large they have monocytic
characteristics during fine blue
cytoplasm extremely large nucleus very
prominent nucleoli and again a case
where the scattergram leads you to
looking for a an acute monocytic
leukemia so you may ask well does the XT
or the xn could you be aware of a
leukemia in an animal since you've just
showed me one people well the answer is
again yes
this particular diagram is down taken
from a dog it certainly looks different
from the normal scatter grams that we've
looked at basically the only thing that
looks normal is perhaps the debris and
dark blue and the eosinophils in bred at
this point it's like okay these are
likely my neutrophils and perhaps some
immature granulocytes but the analyzer
can't know what this is so it's graded
out and you're going to guess it's in
the area of lymphocytes and monocytes so
it's likely lymphocytes or Montes
right or both and it is pretty high up
on this skate on the scale so we
question whether there might be blast
there as well
so here it is as far as numbers with it
and I did a very high white count
typical of leukemias okay so a 69
thousand white count we have small
numbers of immature brands so what we're
seeing going upward here might be
immature grant but the very most
important thing is that it's actually
plus doubt or minus the excuse me - the
lymph and mono population so telling you
in this particular case you absolutely
need the microscopic differential but
the sample did indeed give a blast flag
so it leads us in that direction and
here we are so in this case again we
have high numbers of cells and we have
cells in this case in this before until
they saw seven percent mono blast so
fairly small numbers but significant
numbers of mono blast but 49 percent
monocytes in which this person who did
the differentiation differential has to
fight a lot of them as pro monocytes
which it's to the size lymphocytes were
actually quite normal and we can see
that the classification for this in this
particular dog was an acute milo
monocytic leukemia so indeed the X T and
X n analyzer can predict for you the the
presence of leukemia in animals all
right so let's look now at some of these
RBC and platelet Gaussian curves because
these two can be considered SATA grams
and they also tell us whether we
potentially have abnormalities when we
look at this RBC scattergram
we have a pretty good go CNP but we also
have two other things we have this peak
that occurs before the threshold and we
have a minor peak that occurs after
remember these indicate that red cells
are larger as we go to the right on the
x-axis and that red cells are smaller as
we go left on the F axis small bumps on
the x-axis are the right side often
referred small bumps on the left side
typically refer to small red cells so
they may indicate red cell fragments
important to look as always as the
values that these does max actually
gives you and with this one we can see
and we have an animal that has a pretty
profound anemia one with a 7.3
hemoglobin I talked about the analyzer
being able to give you statistics for
your RDW and as both an SD and CV and we
can see in both cases they are
highlighted it means that these extra
things we are seeing contributes to the
broader SDS CD telling us that there is
a difference in the red cell size
present in this sample we do have some
level over ticks 5% okay so a small
number and we're also flagged on this
sample that there are nucleated Reds and
we're also sample we also flag that I
have a difference between my impedance
and my optical platelets so I have
multiple things to look at I have to
look at both of these what is the cause
for these two extra bumps on both sides
and do indeed I have nucleated frets the
other scattergram from this particular
animal here is the reticular tick I can
see yes I do have an increased number of
rejects indicated by this pink in red in
my in my reticulocyte area
but the most important thing from this
scattergram is that the red cell
themselves are actually shifted downward
so that these cells in our red cell
population are actually erroneously
elevating our platelet count as I said
this was a reason that we went to using
a platelet oh we can see there is
greater separation between our red cell
population blue on the top and our
platelet population which is on the
bottom both of them retexe and platelets
in this case show us that we have
increased production of both red cells
and platelets when we looked at the wnr
we want to see that we have nucleated
Reds and indeed we have an extra
population that is consistent with
nucleated runs that were reported on the
analyzer and again our final
confirmation as always goes to
microscopic evaluation I think this one
you're looking for red zone morphology
so you're looking for something that
correlates to that bump on the left
saying do I have small red cells and
indeed I have multiple small red cells
in here probably enough to make a
visible bump that we saw on the
scattergram do I have nucleated red
cells certainly I have nucleated red
cells that are they're consistent with
increased reticulocytes all right so
let's look at another one and I've
labeled this one for you as haemoglobin
turbidity in like a Nia important thing
is not every bump to the left is a small
red cell and one of the common ones that
you can get in practice is increased
hemoglobin for bida T or Latino so when
you look at this set of data you're
going to again look at the things that
flag for you and one of the most
prominent ones for these are your
indices MCH MCH C or mean cell
hemoglobin concentration in this case I
have nearly a 50 for my mean cell
hemoglobin concentration
hemoglobin is a protein and as such it
has a size to it and as such only so
much hemoglobin protein can fit within
the size of a red cell consequently
hemoglobin analyzers typically pick a
value and with that value you know the
maximum amount of hemoglobin that can
fit into a red cell for most analyzers
this is about 37 grams per deciliter of
hemoglobin when you exceed those values
what is causing the color change in your
hemoglobin determination remember that
is a spectrophotometric Reed is
something that is adding extra color so
it is either extra free hemoglobin it is
extra turbidity or very commonly like
Kimia so these high values are very
important in your diagnostic evaluation
of this scattergram also important for
you to look and check whether the
hemoglobin and hematocrit match if we
remember the match hemoglobin should be
approximately if you multiply it by 3
should equal your hematocrit we can see
if we multiply this 111 by 3 it would
give us a whom adequate of about 33 so
we have a mismatch between hemoglobin
hematocrit fortunately with the analyzer
it does indeed flag turbidity hemoglobin
interference whenever MCHC is greater
than 36.5 it is then us to evaluate what
that reason is for is is it leukemia as
a hemolysis is what is falsely elevating
the hemoglobin some labs will also do a
spun hematocrit to confirm that the
hematocrit is correct and laugh on all
labs would likely do a plasma
replacement you try to get rid of the
interfering color so they can have an
accurate hemoglobin reported and then
recalculate their indices so they too
are accurate
looking at platelet histogram okay we're
going to move to a couple case studies
with platelets just as the red cells it
would hope that it returns to zero on
both ends of the baseline so that there
is lack of interference in this Reed
alright so here is here are two
different dog histograms again from an
ASC BP presentation the one on the left
is a normal dog we see good separation
of red cell and platelets okay and we
see pretty good size wise population
this is a normal dog the one on the
right we see again a pretty good
population of red cells we see a much
higher level of reticulocytes than our
normal animal but the big difference
between now is a lack of platelets we
have a very very small platelet region
and we find and we find that this
population of immature platelet fraction
is the response to the lack of platelets
alright so it included two more platelet
case studies and I included human ones
because the new XM platform has that new
channel that platelet F channel and it's
extremely important for accurate
platelet counts to include and to
consider the results that are seen with
a platelet F channel I thought this was
an excellent example I'll be in human
taken from the University College of
London and they used beta cell I beta
thalassemia major patient and we know in
that patient population there's going to
be numerous fragment cells but you will
have a lot of small result when you look
at that platelet impedance found you're
going to find that there is no baseline
between the platelet pump
the red cell bump it should not be you
should recognize even looking at this
one that the platon impedance count is
giving you an erroneously high count
due to these platelet fragments but when
they ran them they looked actually at
the XE platform and they looked at
platelet oh we said well that should be
better and indeed it looks somewhat
better but you can see that there's
still an overlap between these very
small red red cells in the dark blue and
our painted platelet population in that
aquamarine and if you can see the
presentation there we can see platelet I
was about five hundred thousand whether
it was measured on the X E or the X M so
the platelet I told us this patient had
five hundred thousand platelets when we
looked at platelet o it was a hundred
and eleven thousand and when we looked
at platelet F which in this case is uses
a fluorescent probe Pacific for
platelets we saw 140 so this tells us in
this particular case that was about an
eighty percent error in you if you had
used a platelet i they confirm this by
actually running on flow cytometer CD 61
which is a platelet marker and they
showed that indeed the count was 152
this shows the value of actually having
a fluorescence based count and the value
of the platelet o versus the platelet i
when there are numerous small fragments
and i included this one okay this is
another example of using the platelet F
scatter bram this isn't a case of cute a
few Pro lymphocytic leukemia with chemo
and the presence now of white blood cell
fragments although this is human
certainly we have multiple diagnostic
areas where animals are receiving
chemotherapy so it's still a very
relevant example now let's look on the
left on the Left we have our X II in our
platelet oh and we were saying that many
times platelet o can be better than
then the platelet I important not to
make that a hard and fast wool it's
important to look at data gram and
determine what that arrow gram is
telling you when we look at this plate
widow we ask ourselves does it look
normal and certainly it does not
actually our reso looks pretty small
we do have summary ticks so not too bad
a problem comes when we start looking at
this platelet and we actually have a lie
and level of platelets on the bottom and
then we have this huge mass up here
which the analyzer has tried to divide
between what's the immature platelet
fraction and what might be best and by
doing it it gives us a total platelet
count of one hundred and eighty one
thousand for this particular patient
with leukemia same patient run on the XM
platform with the platelet F now when we
look at the platelet s okay we have
really a good separation between red
cell and platelet and our platelet
parameters seems pretty consistent okay
we have a nice population that seems
pretty consistent not one that seems
okay what's this stuff down here versus
what's the stuff that's of it but what
help a platelet I and the X II was
actually twenty five thousand a level
that would likely be in a critical range
for a leukemia patient the platelet I
was twenty eight thousand so in good
correlation between platelet I good
impedance counts for both of them here's
our platelet oh and this is why I said
not always better
wasn't hundred and eighty one thousand
because of this big mass that was here
and now we compare it to the platelet F
and the platelet half is about twenty
four thousand huge difference and very
significant diagnostic difference that
you were D treating in this case a
patient and assuming they have a very
normal platelet count when indeed they
have a very reduced platelet count
beyond that the platelet fraction the
immature platelet fraction
in the EXCI value gave a value of 41
percent so the physician might think the
bone marrow is actively trying to
compensate and make platelet whereas in
the platelet f we have a 1.1 percent
immature platelet fraction showing us
that we have very little new release of
platelets so I'm really quite excited
about this parameter and I think for our
leukemic and chemo populations it's
going to be a nice addition
alright we'll end it now I'm here so one
more on RBC okay we have another little
bump on the left okay so you're saying
okay well it's small red cells or it's
turbidity and the answer is well maybe
not okay in this case again we have a
platelet that's flagged for us we have a
high MP v on this particular one and you
know platelet I and platelet oh they
didn't have a flag between the two of
them but when we look at the platelets
histogram on this one we see that
doesn't wipe them down to baseline and
in essence this actually was a rat
sample so that 700,000 platelets was
actually kind of low for this particular
species and we can see that they have
they're forcing new generation of
platelets which are these giant
platelets that are there so um when we
look at now our platelet oh we can see
that exactly that's what this rat is
doing we have pretty normal populations
but they have a pretty big immature
threat but work pretty nicely in animals
especially for seeing our regeneration
when you want to see regeneration all
right one more platelet in animals and
again this look kind of look like the
thalassemia example that we had from the
London hospital of people so you can see
we get these in animals to where the
platelet just doesn't go down to
baseline and the red cell continues up
from it when we look at this one it
tells us okay I do have a platelet flag
and and I'm not really pleased with my
platelet i i'm also flagged for that but
other than that this person looks this
animal looks pretty fine
they don't have an anemia everything
else looks fairly decent except we have
some high success is these us at a gram
is abnormal
alright so it's a very calming problem
this one was actually platelet clumping
in a dog and we know that in animal
samples because of the difficulty in
drawing it can be very common to get
some interference from platelet clumping
so could we put this platelet o OS that
there might have been something there
with them we can see that we kind of
have a now instead of a discrete
population of platelets to the left and
that nice immature platelet function we
now kind of see a smear of platelets and
that's because we are seeing now
platelets being assessed as clumps of or
essence so whenever you see this
clumping this smearing it's synonymous
with what's truly a clumping that you
would see morphologically okay all right
another one that was given by ASB CP and
i thought was relevant for this
population and a good learning example
was looking at the reticulocyte
scattergram and where those population
falls typically normally you could draw
a line through the midpoint of your red
cell population and your Hritik swil
fall right on it and your reject and
your your red cell and your platelet
populations will have a good separation
this particular example showed us
microcytic red cells with iron
deficiency and the dog we see when we
draw that same line down the middle that
the cells that are being produced are
actually pretty small because of the
lack of iron to fully make those
hemoglobin molecules so this they
labeled as a microcytic iron to fish
the anemia and you can ask yourself do I
have problems with any of my other
counts and you might say if I could have
a problem with a platelet count and this
you might want to evaluate simply
because those new cells are actually so
small in this animal so again and
enhance flagging the exome will actually
do a flagging and it will do that
measurement for you how far is the red
cell from my platelet population and how
far and can I determine whether I am
seeing a level that might be synonymous
with hyperthermia or not
so these additional flagging 's help us
in really determining microcytic
hypochromic anemia whether they're in
people as this demonstrates or or
animals it just is going to measure and
flag and here is that iron deficiency
now in a dog showing you that it
actually exists - we can see in those
cases I'm not seeing a bump but I'm
seeing that my Gaussian curve actually
goes over the threshold because the
cells are smaller than normal they fall
below the threshold and when I confirm
microscopically I do indeed see those
small cells I do see hypochromic cells
and just as we've looked at a couple
times I see that the platelet count
fails to return to baseline and I will
likely have to look for my platelet
count to make sure I'm reporting an
accurate level the last - okay the very
last year we look at now are a case of
parasites and certainly we have
parasites and animals this one again
happens to be a human and this one is
the only one that's actually taken from
the EXCI but I take it because it is
relevant you see parasites and animals
and you can see them pretty consistently
so it's an important learning lesson the
two cases on the left or humans that had
no malarial they were malaria
negative you can see normal populations
within their wdf and normal populations
within their wnr when they went three
other individuals who had Plasmodium
vivax were analyzed you're not going to
see a signature but you see differences
in all of them if you look closely you
can now see I have multiple populations
where you should have a single
neutrophil I now have two aqua or I have
to braid categories they also look like
my iou's have multiple population my W
in our channel I have although difficult
to see here because it's dark blue but I
have some arrows I have more debris and
the debris have shifted off to the left
so why do I have more debris and why do
I have more populations and in this case
indeed it was malaria
okay so we'll area is one ticular if
you're working in monkey colonies and
you know that we capital area there but
you could have Bo BC OSIS you could have
a number of different parasites it's
important to remember that these
parasites can have very large nuclei in
them they indeed can stained with this
being a same so they can be seen as a
another sort population and also these
parasitic infected cells sometimes are
kind of lice resistant and because of
that we see larger debris pile agents
and the very last one okay also related
to our debris population back into an
animal this is actually a sickle cell
model showing that lice resistance so
with it you can see that I have a debris
population but just like platelet clumps
I have this big smear of something so it
shows that there's a problem in this
particular sample and in this particular
one happened to be a sickle cell mouse
model showing a level of of lice
resistance
so to summarize important to know that
the knowledge of sis mix scattergram
interpretation is a very useful first
step in hematologic disease diagnosis
both in humans and in your veterinary
species and when we learn and understand
the pathologic changes in these scatter
grams it's going to be similar whether
we're using annex e that's C or an XM
platform but then you might ask well
what does the XM platforms give us that
the XT doesn't and really there's a
number of things it improves throughput
we can actually combine two analyzers
other so really our efficiency and
throughput can be improved it decreases
the amount of sample volume that we need
and for small ends may be like mice um
it that's an important criteria I really
like the improved flagging of our
abnormal scattergram so it helps you not
miss these abnormal findings you have an
automated reporting of nucleated red
blood cells that access to the platelet
f2 that we about to further minimize
erroneous platelet counts and lastly
what we didn't speak about was actually
the automation of a seven-part death
that can be used for body fluids that's
now available on the veterinary platform
so thank you thank you very much dr.
Cresswell for that informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of our webinar if you have
any questions you'd like to ask please
do so now just click on that ask a
question drop down box located on the
far left of your presentation window
type your questions into the box that
appear on the screen and click the send
button we'll answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end so let's
take a look at our first set of
questions coming in from our audience
members and thank you again for your
participation dr. kress well why is
multi-species software necessary to
accurate WBC
parental discrimination okay so I think
we covered that in part of the
presentation but let me get on it once
again because it really is an important
aspect and I will tell you 20 years ago
people ran all their veterinary samples
through the human based hematology
analyzers and it took a while to
recognize that really aren't very
accurate so it is it's absolutely
essential to use a veterinary software
when you're reporting veterinary results
we pointed out that there are low there
morphologically similar white cells
berry it's easy though they can have
different sizes they can have different
shapes they can have different
granularity and these subtle differences
allow the cluster designations to vary
sometimes substantially so because of
that having an accurate differential is
important equally important for a
calving accurate cell count because the
sizes of platelets the sizes of red
cells very largely between species so
it's absolutely essential for accurate
counts and accurate differentials
thank you dr. Cresswell our next
question is what is a benefit of having
the ability to set your own WBC
differential gating alright so we saw
one example where they actually
reanalyze the sample so so that's one
advantage that if you can really see how
it's separating you can go through a
reanalysis and and still have obtained
your data beyond that we've actually
found that you can use it for maybe even
alternate applications we've gone
through and actually created a
differential performed on bone marrow
and you do that by knowing what's in
those populations and by by defining
those populations so that can be an
important thing um you know if you're
doing a research study I can say it's
also important that you could set your
gate and then you always know that it's
exactly where it's going to be and the
last example it probably is going to
give in the veterinary world is you may
not know the species you're going to
deal with today versus the species you
deal with tomorrow so being able to set
up your own you can go past the normal
veterinary species that are provided and
you can really analyze anything and the
example I can give is in my past life
who actually supported an aquarium so
the question came well can you do a CBC
on a shark and you do a CBC on a whale
how about a sea lion and the answer
became yes we can do it on all of them
and were they the same no they weren't
but it allows you flexibility which you
really mean in a veterinary world
thank you dr. Cresswell our next
question is the sis max analyzer capable
of performing differentials on samples
other than peripheral blood yeah so I
just mentioned it briefly in the summary
certainly the the X the X n now allows
body fluid analysis which is a nice new
thing and with the ability to set
channels I would say even on the X T
some of us would do things that way
although certainly night better to have
it that it's set up and actually fully
validated so that you don't aren't doing
the validation process yourself but the
answers you asks and I also alluded to
we've been able to do bone marrow
differentials so so the answer is yes
you can use it for four other fluid
types thank you so much
if I want to thank our audience again
for their questions and any questions
that aren't answered today will be
receiving emails to your questions after
the presentation dr. Cosmo would you
like to provide the audience members
with any closing remarks before we close
today well I guess I will say I've had a
long history of looking at hematology
scatter grams I've also always found
them fun and informative I hope the
audience have have enjoyed it
and I would encourage them to learn more
about it because it's going to provide
better service to your customers by
knowing what you're looking at in these
abnormal scatter grams wonderful thank
you and thank you for your presentation
and for your tremendously important
research I'd also like to thank lab
routes and system X for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through May of 2018
you'll receive an email from lab roots
letting you know when this webcast will
be ready for a replay please share this
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event
that's all for now and thank you for
joining us we hope to see you again soon
bye bye